einer der Entdecker der ebolasäuche
schlägt jetzt Alarm Peter Po hat im
Wissenschaftsmagazin Science die späte
Reaktion der Weltgesundheitsorganisation
WHO kritisiert deshalb könne es bis zu
20.000 infizierte geben jeden Monat zu
US-Wissenschaftler die aktuelle
Entwicklung von Ebola jetzt in Klicks
und science and
fiction die Ebola seuchche hat sich
jetzt wirklich zu einer ziemlich
schlimmen Katastrophe entwickelt
dramatisch ist die Situation vor allem
jetzt Anfang September geworden in der
libanischen Hauptstadt Monrovia hat sich
die Zahl der wöchentlich infizierten
vervierfacht jetzt sind es dort mehr als
200 pro Woche überall steigen die Zahlen
innerhalb eines Monats haben sie sich
verdoppelt das heißt im letzten Monat
sind genauso viel Menschen infiziert
worden wie in all den Monaten zuvor
insgesamt sind es jetzt 5300 und die
Zahl der Toten ist auf 2600 gestiegen
US-Wissenschaftler sehen die Entwicklung
jetzt viel skeptischer als die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation who wähend
die WHO mit einer Dauer von so 9 Monaten
rechnet und 20.000 infizierten insgesamt
kalkulieren US Wissenschaftler jetzt mit
18 Monaten und eben bis zu 20.000
infizierten im Monat womit dann auch das
Risiko der Ausbreitung über Afrika
hinaus deutlich steigen würde nachdem
US-Präsident Barack Obama jetzt 3000
Soldaten in die Krisenregion geschickt
hat ist auch Deutschland aktiv geworden
aktuell will die deutsche Regierung in
Zusammenarbeit mit der französischen
Armee eine Luftbrücke einrichten vom al
aus sollen Hilfsgüter nach Liberia
Guinea und Sierra Leone geflogen werden
das ausftige Amt halte mit das bis zu
100 Soldatinnen und Soldaten einen
lufttransportstützpunkt in der Region
aufbauen und die Luftbrücke in Betrieb
nehmen sollen das soll diese Woche noch
passieren des Weiteren wurde die
finanzielle Unterstützung von 17
Millionen um weitere 15 Millionen Euro
ausgebaut letzte Woche wurde in Sierra
Leone landesweit eine dreitägige
Ausgangssperre verhängt
Regierungssprecher Abdullah baralai
begründete diesen Schritt damit dass so
der Körperkontakt und somit die
Verbreitung des Erregers kurzzeitig
eingedämmt werden könne wenn dieser
Ausgangssperre werden
desinfektionsmaterialien an alle
Haushalte verteilt dabei bewegen sich
die freiwilligen Helfer meist in
viererguppen das ist nötig geworden da
es immer wieder zu Übergriffen auf
Helfer gekommen ist im Südosten gyneas
wurden sogar Helfer umgebracht dort
waren drei Ärzte in Begleitung einiger
Journalisten unterwegs um über die
Krankheit zu informieren im Verlauf des
Besuchs wurden die Besucher mit Steinen
beworfen und schließlich gewaltsam
weggezerrt das Schicksal der Helfer und
Journalisten war zunächst unklar aber
drei Tage später teilte guneas
Regierungssprecher mit dass insgesamt
acht Leichen gefunden worden sein
darunter auch Journalisten zweifelsfrei
wurden sie ermordet die Täter hatten ein
intolerables und unakzeptables Maß an
Grausamkeit gezeigt sagte der
Ministerpräsident von ger Mohamed seit
vor Fahner das Misstrauen gegenüber den
Helfern ist halt sehr sehr groß
besonders die Schutzanzüge erregen
Besorgnis so kommt es immer wieder zur
Ausschreitung als im August ein Markt
mit Chlor desinfiziert werden sollte kam
unter den Passanten das Gerücht auf das
Virus würde absichtlich und gezielt
verbreitet werden wie wird es
weitergehen im August hat die WHO
bereits den internationalen
gesundheitsnotfall ausgerufen damit kann
die Organisation n völkerrechtlich
verbindliche Vorschriften zur Bekämpfung
der Epidemie erlassen noch in diesem
Monat soll die Mission an mir United
Nations mission for Ebola emergency
response gestartet werden dafür steht
ein halbjahresbudget von 800 Millionen
Euro zur Verfügung daran beteiligen sich
130 Länder so viel wie noch nie in der
Geschichte der Vereinten Nationen und
nach Einschätzung der UNO kann die
Epidemie in sech bis 9 Monaten in den
Griff bekommen werden dazu müsse
allerdings eine globale Reaktion
erfolgen also weltweit
zusammengearbeitet werden das bedeutet
dass der momentane Einsatz gegen den
reger 20 Mal so hoch sein müsste und das
ist eine Menge äh ja wie sich die Ebola
Epidemie entwickelt hat könnte in dieser
Playlist sehen vom ersten bis zum
letzten Beitrag und das gleiche gilt
auch im Blog dort gibt's noch mehr
Meldung da müsst ihr HIER KLICKEN es
gibt glaube ich keine Webseite die so
ausführlich über Ebola berichtet hat wie
klicksub alle Links auch in der
Videobeschreibung und was meint ihr wird
die Menschheit die solche einnehmen
können diskutiert es mit mir in den
Kommentaren bis dann bleibt dran